I turn to my left and I now see DP of
the DP show Dan Patrick who will be
handing out this baby right here in
between the two of us this Vince
Lombardi Trophy
on NBC on Sunday night how are you Dan
I'm good now I don't hold this thing by
the way you don't ever hold it right you
don't think I have because the
Commissioner usually it's a Hall of
Famer who brings it up do you know who
it is this year yet I do not okay and
you I'll go through the ceremony on
Friday rehearsal on Friday for this but
even then I may not know who is bringing
the trophy up and they go through the
the players will be touching it I love
that that is my favorite part of that
that postgame ceremony and then the
Commissioner is there the hall-of-famer
gives the Commissioner of the trophy he
holds it then he hands it to the owner I
just sort of moderate them well and what
you do as well as you don't relinquish
the microphone I mean how hard of a grip
do you have on that bike well you
normally have you don't want to show
it's like a golf grip you know it's it's
right you just want to make sure that
you're holding the club do you interlock
pinky sometimes I'll do a Varden grip on
it and but you want to make sure that I
have to judge you right away
now when you when the owner grabs that
microphone or puts his hand on the
microphone now I have to know is he
holding it away or is he just holding it
there maybe because at a comfort or
nervous or not sure what to do with his
hands once you sense that there's a
little bit of inertia like there's
something going on here that's when you
have to make sure you I have to send a
message who's the owner with who's the
owner that you've been up there well
before it's been the Patriots right
Steve Tisch with the Giants and Robert
Kraft both I had to do a little pull
back like a kung fu mr. Rooney did not
okay there was no there was no trouble
with with that okay but mr. Kraft will
occasionally grab it and he thinks he's
got five minutes at the improv and stood
that too and and I'm holding Steve dish
that was that was a struggle cuz he's a
big guy so I had you know I had to size
up my opponent
when I'm up there right like I want to
see you know uh Laurie with the Eagles I
mean I don't know how strong he is but I
have to do my background work to see if
he was like a wrestler yes cool sure you
know well you're professional yes I may
be your profession you have to go you
have to go a little bit deeper here to
understand just how strong that owner is
DP here on the Rich Eisen show and of
course you're also hosting the pregame
show that is how long it's only five
hours soft I know I know
come on where's the extra three and a
half hours that's where we gave it to
you guys because they said do you want
to do eight hours and I said I think
Rich Eisen would like to do eight yeah
and I you didn't talk to me before that
I guess I would have I did not because I
sliced that at least in half eight is
tough eight and a half don't forget that
half that's a crusher like when you get
to eight and you go I don't know if I
can go a half hour and I know just can't
it's exhausted I can't do it well part
of your duties as well is you're
interviewing you're interviewing Brady
today correct for for tonight for Super
Bowl Sunday okay final hour there so
when he shows up for media day you're
gonna get 15 minutes with him I will
already have talked to him before me you
will have okay so it's 7:00 to 10:00
tonight how are you how are you
attacking is the wrong word obviously
but how are you approaching this
interview what are you planning what do
you want to get out of Tom Brady dan I
want stories that's all just stories or
just something that because they this
isn't a gotcha moment this isn't you
know where I'm gonna it's not a 60
Minutes interview I don't have the time
I got 15 minutes so what what can I give
you that the football fan the final half
hour is interested in and that's all I'm
trying to do is be respectful of him
hopefully he can play a little bit he's
friendly and you know wants to tell you
some things he knows you knows your work
as well he knows you're not gonna go in
and call this kid a pissant and you're
not gonna go in there and know and and
bring up well I mean you are gonna at
some point are you gonna bring up his
future with New England I mean that that
to me is is still that's still lingers
that is
an open-ended question but but I don't
know if he knows that that's the problem
well the the the by all accounts he
Bella check and craft are going to have
a sit-down they are going to sit in the
room together and hash out whatever in
the heck is going on there but I thought
this year was gonna be as last year I
thought this was the scenario they keep
Garoppolo Brady wins the Super Bowl and
then there's an amicable parting yes I
don't think Giselle went on the CBS
Morning Show and said by accident that
Thomas had concussions I think that was
it felt premeditated of I want this out
there because I you know she's human she
wants him home they got kids he's 40 you
know let's enjoy our life I thought that
was the scenario I thought Garoppolo was
gonna take over and I thought Tom win or
lose was this was his final year and now
he seems in Bolden to almost prove what
I've been doing with my body and my
health
watch me do that in front of you instead
of saying hey go out and do this your
results may vary he's saying watch me do
this wealth to me in the same way that
LeBron is sticking with his program
because what him winning helps set him
up for whatever his next act is going to
be as a producer or an actor or whatever
he so chooses that Brady's current act
and next act is about his body and his
health and him continuing to do this and
win a Super Bowl at his age he's already
the oldest to get here he's the oldest
to do pretty much everything that he's
done this year and to go back-to-back
and then that's the thing I think that
will have bind him craft and Belichick
in the same room as well as the
contracts that Kraft has both of those
is let's do this let's be the first to
do it back to back to back the greed is
good strategy I think is working for all
of them and that's why I think Brady is
not going anywhere
it's not that he lost a lot to get to
this point you know because some
athletes when you start to lose it then
you have doubt because you can't go back
to that or
you have to learn how to play your
position in whatever sport it is that
you like Roger Federer's had to develop
his game differently now he's not that
athletic freak you know 20 years ago I
think Brady is not that far removed of
who he was in how he played in his
athleticism when he started not to say
you're not a great athlete he's he's
he's an intelligent athlete yes and uses
what he he knows his weaknesses and his
strings so it's not like he goes boy
I've lost something now maybe he's lost
some more arm strength but what else did
he lose is he sharper is his you know
mental tough like those kind of things
he's better I think he is I think he's
the you know he's the best at - he's the
best at throwing the ball in a spot that
Grant gains the flag more than anybody
else yeah yeah he's he'll put it in this
Motte might not be caught but it's
definitely gonna be some sort of
interference or illegal contact or
something he's just there's nothing like
it so you're gonna open them up with a
with a with you know what your first
question is to break I have an idea
but since you'll be watching this show
now yeah well I mean I don't I don't
want to give him a heads up it's not
like we're given the questions to
Hillary Clinton you know I'm curious his
memories what's he think of with
Minneapolis or Minnesota that's a good
one where's my nice opener
that's a nice help I am fascinated
though of you know having lost my mom of
you know trying she's on the west coast
he's on the East Coast she's going
through cancer and he's still trying to
you know head up this empire here that
are the New England Patriots then you go
to the Super Bowl she goes to the Super
Bowl
you know she who knows how he'll win she
almost didn't make by the way and I
can't I wasn't a given that she'd be
there to process that right we're like
you can't be overwhelmed by 28 to 3 if
you know your mom just made it to the
Super Bowl like in his mind I don't know
if he said you know this isn't
insurmountable
that's what Edelman said to him the NFL
Films microphone picked them picked up
Edelman saying look you know if your
mom's been through all this but you know
we could pretty much go through this
well I'm not surprised at that but that
that's another one of those elements
that you the degree of difficulty of 28
to 3 but also 28 to 3 and your mom is
coming back from cancer and you don't
even know if she's gonna be able to make
it then she met like I I don't know I
have great admiration for who he is and
what he is and how he's done it and I
we're lucky I've you this is I got to
cover Jordans titles when I was at ESPN
I view it the same way with Brady to be
able to be up on that podium maybe one
more time with him you know I'm very
very fortunate or it could be false
there'd be a great story too absolutely
and you know people say who you're
rooting for if you said it goes down to
the wire and you know New England wins
by 1 or Philly wins I couldn't care less
they're like don't you root I go I root
for a great story I learned long ago you
can always tell a great story and you
can tell it for a long time if somebody
gets blown out you don't tell the story
very long well the last time you gave
out the trophy looked like you're giving
it to Seattle and then New Orleans
showed up on the podium and you said
just when you thought it can't get any
better than that then came last year's
come back in first overtime game but
when you think of being on the sidelines
so I'm I'm behind the goalposts as
Seattle sends the play in and as I watch
this unfold in slow motion I I think
there's a run pass option with Russell
Wilson that's what I think is gonna
happen and I see him get ready to throw
and I went oh my god he can't think oh
my god he he just did they just lost
this Super Bowl so I'm watching this
then the other time was when the Giants
played the Patriots and Eli has the pass
to Manningham Manningham is right in
front of me
as I'm on the sidelines because I'm
getting soon as the game's over I'm on
the field on the podium I mean it
happens fast the other one was the
Cardinals take the lead on the Steelers
I'm on the sidelines with Steve Young
and all of a sudden Steve is doing
play-by-play with Roethlisberger so I
got a Hall of Fame quarterback who's
analyzing Roethlisberger saying it's you
don't realize how brilliant this was you
have the touchdown pass I go to the
podium I don't even know like I'm
thinking I got you know bid well I got
an interview
Kurt Warner and Larry Fitzgerald and
next thing I know I'm on the podium I
don't know who the MVP is of that Super
Bowl with the Steelers and the Cardinals
I'm yelling down to anybody there people
are all and nobody's talking to me
I got Roethlisberger here who might
think he thinks is the MVP and I got the
Commissioner here
Joe Namath is getting ready to bring the
trophies and I have no idea who the MVP
is so I'm like thank you cuz I I wanted
it I think Ben thought he was gonna be
the MVP and I wouldn't be awkward
where I go um and it should have been me
it should have been Ben he was made of
all those throws it was an unbelievable
catch that two-minute drill with Ben is
underrated how great that was but the
chaos that goes on after the game and
then it's over and then you walk off the
field and I've never felt prouder than
the first time I ever did it when I was
in Tampa because I didn't tell my
brothers her sisters nobody in my family
knew I was handing out the trophies yeah
and I walked off and I remember checking
my phone and my brothers and sisters
were like awesome awesome DP I look
forward to seeing it again this week man
thanks for stopping good luck guys you
got it in 60 seconds we are back with
his compadre from football night in
America Rodney Harrison when we come
back in 60 seconds the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience